okay we've been talking basically since
even before Donald Trump was elected
about the coalescing and catalyzing of
white supremacy and extremism in the
United States and my general view my
instinct at the beginning was that
Donald Trump is not creating white
supremacy he's not creating
anti-semitism he's not creating bigotry
probably but he is number one sort of
coalescing it and number two making the
bigots and the white supremacists and
the anti-semites more comfortable being
out in the open
being more public about their extreme
views and is getting them actually
organizing to a greater degree now that
was my idea early on and it does seem to
be borne out including by the former and
even current white nationalists and
white supremacists that we've spoken to
I was recently reviewing in preparation
for this story my interview a couple of
years ago with white nationalist Richard
Spencer
he's someone in the movement and again
he believes you know Trump's not
literally one of us and it's not clear
that he's creating more of us but he is
kind of fomenting this environment in
which we are more likely to thrive or to
do well or whatever the case may be here
organize we now have a report from the
anti-defamation league and the report is
called hate beyond borders the
internationalization of white supremacy
and the report shows two things number
one it shows that white supremacy is
under trump but really over the last two
years Trump is just a piece of what's
going on being internationalized meaning
that there are more links and and sort
of flow of white supremacist
organization across country lines
including from the United States to
Europe and we'll dig into that in more
detail in a second the other thing that
the ADL report shows is that there is
also more weaponization of white
supremacy and my interpretation of
weaponization is that what they're
talking about is turning the ideas into
activism it doesn't necessarily have to
mean physical violence but it's
taking of the ideas and weaponizing them
by making them real activism this is a
really well done study and it combines
sort of the political circumstances that
are fueling this as well as the
technological circumstances because
that's a big thing as well we recently
interviewed former white supremacist
Frank mink and he said there is now an
ability to be radicalized and to have
these extreme communities exist
completely digitally completely over the
internet because of the technology that
exists so I'll tell you about some of
the factors at play
number one the white supremacist
conference scene has grown dramatically
over the last couple of years it
includes American and European
extremists everywhere from Sweden Russia
and Estonia having in-person events and
they are internationalized you have
people flying all over to go to these
white supremacist events that is one
element that is weaponizing and
internationalizing white supremacy you
have the far-right nationalist parties
in Europe some of those parties have
ties to neo-nazis directly a plain plain
and simple others it's a little bit more
nuanced and sort of guised but they are
serving as a sort of central point of
contact for many white supremacists that
were previously isolated in a sense the
immigration debate in both Europe and
the United States has been another I
guess you would call it like a uniting
issue for white supremacists who are
looking to become more active in
immigration has been an issue that has
coalesced and catalyzed a lot of that
activism into something particular a
policy a policy demand so to speak that
these folks can rally around technology
we have to understand that the internet
messaging Facebook Twitter gab whatsapp
that is enabling technology that allows
these groups and ideologies to cross
country lines far more easily so for
example you've got the us-based group
women for Aryan unity yeah they now have
chapters in Europe so the immediate
question is what is it that needs to
happen the first thing is an electoral
prescription which is the nationalist
leaders that are if not directly
supporting this
kind of indifferent li allowing the
environment in which this stuff grows
and it becomes weaponized those leaders
need to be removed or stripped of power
or marginalized depending on what the
government system is in the United
States this includes you've got to
remove Donald Trump period in other
countries you're talking about
representation in a parliamentary system
in a representative system really have
to look at the particulars but the
leaders that are fomenting this
implicitly or explicitly have to be
removed and hopefully we will start
seeing the pendulum swim swing back in
that direction in 2020 once you cross
country lines at least here in the
United States it's possible to designate
these groups foreign terrorist
organizations internationally that may
not mean much but here in the United
States it gives the State Department and
law enforcement more resources and
latitude to fight against these groups
so that's something that should be
looked at as per the Santee defamation
League report the technology companies
because remember technology is a big
piece of what is allowing this to fester
foment and grow the technology companies
they basically already have Terms of
Service that apply to what it is that we
are seeing it's more about enforcing
those Terms of Service and this is a
much bigger issue when I was on the Joe
Rogan program three months ago we talked
a lot of four months ago actually we
talked a lot about the policies
themselves versus their enforcement and
sort of interrelated issues and this is
we could do an entire conversation just
about that and we have but the
enforcement of these policies in ways to
limit these groups ability to recruit
and to spread their messages that's also
important and what we really have to
understand is that these are there are
real-world effects here right we are
seeing terrorist incidents we are seeing
shootings we are seeing Orthodox Jews
being attacked out in public in Brooklyn
and other places we're seeing Jewish
emigration out of certain European
countries like France I believe going
from memory
France has actually seen an outflow of
Jewish residence thanks to the
environment that is
out there so this is not merely it's
easy to say oh this is stuff that exists
on the internet period no there are
groups that are tracking the real-world
impact and it's significant and we're
seeing this stuff pervade the judiciary
we're seeing this stuff pervade law
enforcement here in the United States
and this is a really really good study
that looks at exactly how it is being
both weaponized and internationalized by
a combination of these nationalist
trends that we've been seeing combined
with the technological factors that
allow it to happen we're going to be
following up about this on our Instagram
page at david pakman show on instagram
make sure you're following the show
there and while you're there follow me
as well I posted a picture I am on the
road as many of you who have been
watching the show this week notice I
posted a selfie with Nemo the adderall
dog as some of you know him please don't
take offense to that it's just a joke
and I posted a selfie with him on my
personal Instagram this morning at David
Pakman check it out follow me follow the
show we'll take a quick break and be
back after this